>>> FEDERAL REGULATORS ARE
URGING PELOTON CUSTOMERS WITH
CHILDREN AND PETS TO STOP USING
THE COMPANY'S TREAD-PLUS
EXERCISE MACHINE.
NOW THIS WARNING COMES WITH A
VIDEO.
WE HAVE TO TELL YOU IT'S A
LITTLE JARRING TO WATCH.
IT SHOWS A LITTLE BSTLE BOY PLA
WITH HIS BALL AND HE'S TRAPPED
WHEN HE TRIED TO FREE THE BALL.
HE CAME OUT OF IT OKAY, WE'RE
HAPPY TO REPORT.
CONSUMER PRODUCT SAFETY
COMMISSION SAYS IT'S AWARE OF 39
INCIDENTS WITH THIS MODEL
INCLUDING ONE CHILD'S DEATH.
IN A STATEMENT, PELOTON CALLS
THE WARNING INACCURTE AND
MISLEADING, THE COMPANY SAYS THE
TREAD-PLUS IS SAFE IF THE -- AND
SAFETY WARNINGS ARE FOLLOWED.
THE AGENCY SAYS USERS SHOULD
KEEP IT IN A LOCKED ROOM AND
UNPLUG IT WHEN IT'S NOT BEING
USED.
I HAVE ONE OF THESE TREADMILLS,
I USE IT ALL THE TIME.
EVEN NOW I'M BEING SUPER
CAREFUL.
THE LITTLE BOY TRIED TO HIS
BOB
BALL, YOU COULD SEE THE SISTER
RUNNING FOR THE MOTHER.
>> THE AGENCY SAYING IF YOU TAKE
THE KEY OUT IT WON'T WORK.
>> IT WON'T WORK.
>> THEY'RE SAYING KEEP THAT AWAY
FR